[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout comme
[Musique]
la technologie est encore loin d'être bénigne
il y a encore
euh il y a quelques inquiétudes concernant l'utilisation
de nos
visages pour accéder à des services clés la
technologie biométrique est une sorte de
technologie intrusive dont nous savons qu'elle a  certains
ensembles de préjugés
dont nous savons qu'ils peuvent avoir des problèmes pour
identifier les personnes de couleur
peuvent avoir des problèmes avec les
femmes transgenres tous ces groupes
[Musique]
c'est différent de la reconnaissance faciale
qui est utilisée euh
par exemple dans la surveillance d'accord
donc la grande différence euh entre  ces
deux-là, c'est que
la vérification de phase est un
processus intentionnel, cela oblige les utilisateurs à se présenter en accord
pour donner leur consentement
[Musique]
nous devons être très prudents quant à savoir
si le consentement est
véritablement, vous savez, informé et
librement donné dans ce type de contextes
parlez avec le pouvoir  déséquilibre entre
vous et le gouvernement
mais aussi entre les gens et les
institutions comme les banques et d'autres
qui utilisent ce genre d'
utilisation de ce genre de technologie
[Musique]
merci beaucoup vous